what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so unpopular confession time
unpopular confession time I had never
seen Rick and Morty until like like a
week ago like a week ago
I had not seen Rick and Morty before and
everybody kept telling me it was a
really good show rather like man you
gotta watch Rick and Morty like
McDonald's brought back Szechuan sauce
because Rick and Morty fans made it
happen and I was like no I'm not going
to watch watch Rick good morning because
just looking at like the different you
know images and some of the you know
just not even really watching the show
my initial thought was okay like Rick
and Morty is a show for little kids that
like adults watch this is one of those
like weird situations where it's like
grown adults watching a show for kids
and I'm not gonna be one of those guys
I'm not gonna be one of those guys this
is like a weird are watching it watching
a show for kids as a grown adult that's
not gonna happen
but everyone then I talked to you kept
saying it is so good it was just a war
of attrition right a war of attrition is
what you're waging war against with
enemy and you just bombard them to the
point of they run out of resources and
they can't fight anymore and so I was
like okay I cannot put up with this
anymore I've gotta watch Rick and Morty
see if it's really as good as people say
it is do Rick and Morty's like the best
show ever I love Rick and Morty so much
like it's it's such a cool show like I'm
getting caught up I'm still on season 1
I'm only like five or six episodes and
but I love this show it's it's so good
because it's so like it's an adult show
like it's a show with adult themes you
know and it is really really funny and
interesting to watch so this story is
actually written or really the comics as
far as I'm aware are written in their
entirety by Zach Gorman but the way this
is done by owning press or I guess
already media is that it's really it's
really like like all-star Superman write
those you guys who don't know all-star
Superman is a 12 issue limited series
but all the comics are basically one
shots but it all just kind of tells a
cohesive story and that's what this is I
mean it's almost episodic and the way
that it's done like with the you know
the TV show itself and it all kind of
tells a self-contained story but it
continues on you know with regards to
its own little adventures and escapades
and different things like that and so
initially what it does of course is it
picks up with Rick and Morty you notice
here them kind of engaging with the
family and again the funny thing about
this is that it
Rick is just kind of like lambasted
Jared right because you know Jerry as
the father of Morty is always going on
about like his son's education yeah like
my son needs to go to school he needs to
take his classes because my son Neil is
kind of dumb and he needs to learn you
know although something he's gonna learn
or to be a contributing member of
society you know and in order to just
not be an idiot um the funny thing that
was like just like the show Rick is just
like education is stupid schools are
stupid like you can't learn anything
important in school I guess it's not
really education as TVs like the weight
of schools teach these things is stupid
which is true but it's like you know you
can only ever really learn like going
out in the real world and doing things
for yourself and so the idea here is
that if Jerry's taking the stance that
Morty needs to learn the things that
school teaches in order to make money
then Rick's like well then I'm going to
teach him how to make money like a man
like how to make real money and so what
happened is Rick it basically made this
this device that would allow them to
transverse the space-time continuum they
can jump to different universes and what
they're going to do is they're basically
going to jump to like the multiversal
stock exchange they're going to gamble
they're gonna jump into the stock market
and that's why I love this so much is
because it's like what a terrible
influence like Rick is a terrible
influence on Morty he's like we can
always take shortcuts you know like we
can always we can always cheat we can
always like you know try to take the
quick and easy road of sort of learning
what we need to learn or to actually
understand what it is that we're doing
is like let's just take the quick and
easy path now the funny thing about this
is halfway through they're met up with a
guy by the name of tock the time
detective and all those guy dances make
make clock puns that's all he does is
make time puns the whole time that's all
he does is make time puns I really
didn't mean to make a time prime there
but that's not Lee does he's like I'll
be watching you watch watching you it's
it's so weird to me because there are
instances in the come again even the
show where it's just like okay I mean
this jokes kind of gone on long enough
and there's other times where she's like
I need more jokes I need more jokes now
the funny thing about this is that
Morty's like hey look man we can't do
this because we're breaking the rules we
have to stay within the rules and rich
responsive like yeah man I bet the
chicks love that chicks love you
like living within the confines of the
rules like chicks love you for like not
going out and doing anything interesting
or unique possibly dangerous maybe
something that could they could lay
waste to the entire space-time continuum
yeah I'm sure they dig you for doing
that mister I follow the rules and I
keep my pants perfectly trimmed and
ironed and my shirts are crisp and
they're always tucked in just
weird-looking you look like a serial
killer
like yeah I'm sure the chicks dig you
about that but that's what I love about
Morty right like because even Morty in
and of himself it's just like a little
awkward like he's just like a little off
I mean we don't really know what makes
him off we just know there's like
something a little off about it and it's
funny because like we run into these
situations all the time right like those
awkward scenarios that we wish we could
avoid like you and a friend are walking
somewhere and you're like okay man I'll
see you later only for the two of you
don't realize you're walking in the same
direction in which case there's only one
reasonable you know path for you to
pursue there and this is just like run
to your destination that's the only
reasonable thing you can do otherwise
you're going to be caught up in that
whole situation of awkwardness and
nobody wants to be in that awkward
situation but the funny thing about this
too and this is this is why I love it
because it's always just like at any
moment Morty could be killed because of
Rick's schemes Rick is like hey look man
like what they're going to do is they're
going to analyze you and make sure that
you're you're from like the right
continuum but you're actually you know
betting on stocks from from your right
universe once we pass this test then
we'll be able to go ahead and we'll be
able to just start engaging in the stock
market and that's what they do they
basically just kind of start gambling
you know and so on and so forth you know
betting on stocks and they make a whole
lot of money you know it's like Morty
and Rick incorporates now the funny
thing about this this is really more
like a meta textual situation right like
it's really more of kind of looking at
the idea of how people view the stock
exchange and how it can be used for
example there are lot of people who
looks at look at stocks it's like yeah
man stocks like an easy way to make
money you know buy low sell high
oh yeah unless you're a day trader
you're probably not going to make a lot
of money off the stock exchange and the
stock exchange is not something that you
that you bet on for the long term like
you don't go in and buy stocks of like
abc123 you know that that that battery
company from those those MIT graduates
like you don't you don't bet on that for
the long haul like you bet on them to
Brearley or for a short amount of time
but anything can happen that will change
anything for example in Japan energy
stocks were going at $100 a share with
regards to the nuclear program then the
nuclear like the whole nuclear meltdown
and they were trading at $1,000 share I
watched it happen like I was always
watching it all just unfold and I was so
mad because I didn't get in on the whole
ground level when it all started blowing
up but mutual funds are what you get
invested in for the long haul when
you're investing for retirement mutual
funds is what you go into I did not mean
to turn this into a lesson about the
stock exchange but it's just
misconceptions people have like this
stock market is easy money and that's
really what it is just kind of pointing
you know poking fun at that whole thing
of people just failing to completely
understand how the stock market works so
if the other half of this is that we
really also get a little bit of the
cowardice of Jerry and that's really the
importance of this first issue because
keep in mind with Rick and Morty being
as popular as it is most people who
would pick up this comics have already
seen the show but there are some who
have it there's you know somebody just
kind of wandering through a common
bookstore one day and they see it coming
that says Rick and Morty and they just
go ahead and buy it and in a lot of ways
this comics written for them but only
insofar as it kind of refreshes them
with the character and says look if you
want an award go watch the TV show so
it's one's designed to kind of benefit
the other and it's really a two-way lane
or two-way street but the fact remains
here that we end up having like this
giant robot cat that shows up and as
soon as it makes us appear it terrifies
the hell out of Jerry out of Morty's dad
and Jerry to start scouring you know in
a fetal position now this is funny
because in the show like Jerry's wife
Beth she has no respect for Jerry she's
just like yeah Jerry like you're lame
and you're a coward you know you are if
you're every year the opposite of what
any man should be and it's kind of funny
because this comes to a head when talk
to Tom detective comes knocking on the
door Jerry that is like hey man like I
believe I can help solve your problem of
course Tom Tom a detective exists to
basically shine light on the schemes of
Rick and Morty and to basically bring
their crimes to light which again is
where this is going to kind of take a
total crazy turn in the next video but
the fact remains here that we also get a
little bit of like back and forth
between the two because with regards to
the success that they've had I'm already
kind of gets a little bit carried away
right I mean Mort is just kind of like
yeah man like look I'm the one whose
name is on this company I'm the one
that's you know Devon with all the risk
and that's usually the way it goes
Rick will come along and say okay right
here's my here's my genius idea let's go
do this thing and then like Morty's mech
is the one that's always on the line
right like if anybody is going to die in
a scenario it's gonna be Morty like if
anybody is going to go to prison for all
eternity and some other dimensional
realm
it'll be Morty like it's always Morty
who's
beca's online and that's what this is
designed to feed into right I mean this
is not designed to basically act as
though the Rick and Morty show has never
happened it's designed to kind of feed
on what we already know about the show
and that's kind of a funny thing you
know is because they'll mortgage
response here is like every single time
we get into a scheme like I'm always the
one who's going to have his neck on the
line like I'm always the one who's going
to be in the most danger like I'm the
one running the show here right now your
company only exists because I allow it
to because my name was on the dotted
line and so what is it happening is in
the midst of them kind of getting into
an argument and actually Morty trying to
kick Rick out well then suddenly like
the fuzz show up right like like the
heaps onto them the five-o because it's
just surrounding the house and so while
they're making their escape Rick and and
and more you're caught up with by the
cops and Rick responses well I should
have done like I'm gonna do the thing
that I should have done anything any of
all this which is just shooted the cop
and that's why I hit such a crazy comic
is because it's it goes from like
reasonable to absolutely bananas and
like the blink of an eye right it's just
you know you're driving it and suddenly
it's just a total 90 degree turn into
the realm of absolute insanity and so
what we find out is that in the midst of
this whole shootout once they were
arrested the whole thing is being
broadcast by like these aliens from
another dimension from Yale within the
multiverse that are basically saying
yeah man like these two guys who are
manipulating the stocks you know they
were being they're being arrested for
their crimes and so on and so forth and
one of the people that's being
referenced here is a guy named named
flea bulb rock flea bulb rocks now as we
know this is basically a play on Zaphod
Beeblebrox the guy who was played by Sam
Rockwell the greatest character in the
history of Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy the absolute best character I
love I love to beeblebrox if you guys
never saw Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy
you are supremely missing out but what
just does is it basically transitions to
the next issue which is when they're put
on trial and that's why I say this is
really kind of like you know they're
one-shots they're kind of self-contained
um but it's also you know kind of feeds
into a larger story in terms what you
would see in like a TV episode or
something along those lines but I
absolutely love these comics whose
comments are really really insane but
you know Indy days are kind of my days
you just sort of upload stuff that I
think is kind of you know out there so
that I think just really kind of fun but
if you guys are new here to come to
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob port if
you guys want to see more
Kanwar yourself make sure you hit the
like button and leave a comment down
below and for the one millionth time the
one millionth time people keep asking
when do we get more Walking Dead I said
in the last video we're caught up that
means we have to wait and still the
story finishes before we can do some
more otherwise we're just doing in Capri
stories so yeah anyway The Walking Dead
will come out when that story arc
finishes and then we'll catch up there
there's six there they're released
monthly so we have to wait like six
months sometimes seven for a new story
to come out anyway guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end and
I will catch you all in it peace
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]